[Music]
hey everyone welcome to eyes on
enterprise where I'm bringing on
Googlers to talk about the technology
landscapes that are helping enterprises
scale adapt and modernize my name is
Stephanie Wong and today I have Sona
Oakley solution architect here at Google
cloud very important topic that we're
covering today we're talking about
migration to the cloud and diving into
strategies and the tools to help you get
there there's a lot that we're gonna
cover today so I want to thank you so
much for being on the show absolutely
thank you so much for having me I'm
really excited to come on the show and
talk about migrations great so huge
topic
first off migration is something that
people often consider for a long period
of time because they have rightful
concerns of removing their workloads to
the cloud and then on top of that small
companies versus large companies have
different needs and migration paths so
how do you start to dissect that process
yes absolutely I would say that the
first thing that you want to start with
because migrations is such a heady topic
is you want to start with the why ask
yourself the question why are we going
down this path what is going to be the
business goal that I'm accomplishing or
even the technical goal that I'm
accomplishing and once you kind of frame
that and keep that in mind it really
makes it clear how we can get from where
your company is today to where it is
that you want to be and whether that's
being able to develop faster whether
that's being able to take advantage of
all of the efficiencies and scale that
moving to the cloud can bring it'll
really vary based on your business and
your business and how big your business
is what your business goals are so there
are a lot of ways to move to the cloud
and along with it many considerations
when you're picking a strategy you know
some companies want to decommission some
workloads they want to consolidate
others want to move their VM to the
clouds and others want to modernize by
transforming into containers so how do
you start in that decision-making
process essentially the way that you'd
want to think about it is that once we
have that Northstar that we want to
accomplish we want to go back to square
one and really start to build a catalog
of all of the applications that you have
the workloads that you're thinking about
moving what your networking and security
requirements are and once we've
categorized and built out that list we
can start to think about what am I
strategy is moving forward now when I
say that a lot of people think in their
minds that they need a very complicated
system diagram where there's all these
connections taking place you know where
we have the exact schematics of the way
that our applications work for larger
enterprises and businesses that have
grown organically sometimes that's not
feasible so I would say that you know
coming to the table with anything even
if it's just a napkin which has happened
to me a customer showed up with a napkin
of just all their applications and
workloads written down but they wrote
down on the flight to to come up to
Mountain View so I would say that even
something that simple gives us a good
starting point and gives us an idea of
at least what is top of mind for you and
then we can go through and dig through
with the other various groups and
business lines of business that you have
to figure out you know what are other
applications but our other resources
that are being nice
so going back to the first part of the
work flow collecting inventory it can
include a lot of things like
dependencies on your app stack including
your database and message brokers and
then you have your infrastructure
underlying it firewall rules security
policies am I missing anything there I
mean that really covers the meat of it
and then things like source code
repositories oftentimes the the gotchas
happen when a business grows organically
and we see you know people coming out of
the woodwork as this migration process
is happening hey actually I'm keeping my
source code over here not in the
official repository or I've got this
machine that I'm using 2% of CPU on for
my you know for my own workloads things
like that comprehensive evaluation ahead
of time is gonna save you in the long
run yes so I know that there are a lot
of cases where moving to the cloud might
not be practical or it's just not
technically feasible in the near term so
you know like for example you have
licenses that you can't move to the
cloud or your tech stack may not be
virtual izybelle in some cases or you
have third-party frameworks and
languages being used so what do you do
in those cases yeah I would say that in
those cases it's okay to say no and
sometimes no is the right answer for
example you know their mainframes are
not going away we've predicted that they
will be for the past 40 years and
they're they're here to stay so you know
if you have legacy applications that are
running in those kinds of environments
it's totally fine to leave them where
they are and then to focus on what we
and accomplished because the last thing
we want to do is kind of get into a
situation where we're trying to force a
square peg into a round hole and we can
also do something that's a close
approximation to moving to cloud so for
example I was working with a company
that was getting close to a data center
shutdown and so instead of having them
move over completely to the cloud what
we did was we move them to a colocation
facility and what that allowed them to
do was it allowed them to still reap
some of the benefits because they're
still located close to a cloud entry
point and are able to get that high
throughput low latency that they were
looking for without doing the official
cloud migration so just jumping off what
you just said there are a lot of ways to
approach this and you have to meet
customers where they are and you know
some may want to do an all-in-one lift
and shift while others prefer to do
hybrid approach private and and public
clouds so how do you advise your
customers in though absolutely I would
say that it again comes back to what the
customer wants you know if most of your
business is on legacy applications that
hardware will have to consider a very
different migration path than if you're
already cloud native and looking to
scale so for example we actually work
with a customer who had very aggressive
timelines to shut down their data center
again this is a very familiar story and
what we did was we advised them to kind
of lift and shift their current
applications as is and then modernize
later because they were facing a really
imminent time crunch that we wanted to
make sure that we could adhere to and
then we can always modernize those
applications and advise on a
containerization strategy at a later
point in time don't feel like you have
to you know do everything at the same
time on the topic of containerization
people often ask ok how do I know if my
application is a good candidate for
container izing and you know pushing up
to the cloud things like test
applications multi-tier stacks lamp
applications or perhaps you have a java
app running on premise web apps how do
you know Google can absolutely help you
in that effort you know especially once
we've done that categorization of
applications but generally the ones that
you mentioned are good for
containerization I would also include in
there are things like training labs you
know thinking also about your
application if it's resilient to
restarts then that is a good one as well
to be moving over and you know again it
just goes back to making sure that
you're not trying
to force a containerization strategy I
was working with a large scale
manufacturing company who really wanted
to go all-in on containers but due to
their kind of technical requirements it
wasn't the right fit for them so instead
we moved them onto system containers
which still gives them a little bit of
that flexibility but isn't that full
container portfolio that we were
originally thinking about so this still
begs the question what do you do with
monolithic applications because I mean a
lot of enterprises are still running off
that how do you migrate to a micro
surface environment the way that I think
about that is you know if you're
thinking about scaling a building or
scaling a mountain you don't try to jump
all the way up to the top at one time
you know you take it step by step and
really go incrementally as your team
learns more about Google Cloud and
kubernetes and containerization we can
break down that application and move
toward more of a micro services strategy
one of the things that Google has done
that's a little bit of a nice middle
ground there is using application
containers so instead of thinking about
containerization in the normal context
an application container allows you to
put the application entire application
into a container and so that way you can
still take advantage of the higher fault
tolerance and portability that
containerization provides without
necessarily moving or breaking down the
monolithic application all right because
I think that what's intimidating is a
full reactor tech chure yeah of these
applications yes absolutely yeah I love
this idea of crap middle ground and
moving in parts because it lowers the
risk and the barrier to entry to cloud
migration and you can still take
advantage of like the Software Defined
Networking live migration fast reboots
but I do want to talk about specifics a
little bit about the tools that exist to
help you migrate like for example moving
compute workloads to the cloud do we
have anything there absolutely so we
have migrated for compute engine and
essentially what that allows you to do
whether you're moving one workload or
thousands it provides you a unified way
to move all of these component Rees over
to Google Google compute engine which is
GCE it also provides cloud testing and
validation we have a plugin that makes
it really simple to kind of find those
to find those workloads and move them
over and then lastly which i think is
the most critical part and you touched
on this at the beginning is that we have
a stateful rollback so if at any point
you feel like you need to hit the
ejector button and really just get out
of the migration we have that capability
where you can roll back to your
on-premise environment we can pause that
you know take a timeout and see what's
happening yes that's very important
because once again you want to make sure
you have compatibility towards the cloud
first and you're not creating disruption
for your user base so being able to
rollback as a key I think yes absolutely
one of the customer examples that I
always like to use is that we had a
fortune 500 company who was using sa P
actually implement a their original
considering of multi cloud strategy and
then they moved over to GC P and what we
helped them do was we helped them run sa
P on Google cloud platform which was
really important because they were part
of the pharma business and that was
important for their Pharma in healthcare
verticals we all in all I believe
covered something like 7000 systems
across 30 different applications with 12
terabytes of data
moving on to GC P and all of that was
done with migrate for compute engine oh
great another great example of a very
common use case is vmware migration to
the cloud do we have a tool that exists
for that as well if you've decided that
retaining use of a VMware based control
plane is what's appropriate for your
business we can actually support that
and we have support for VMware vSphere
workloads that we can move over onto
Google cloud platform awesome so what
about the applications that do need to
stay on premise yet they want to take
advantage of the cloud native
capabilities what do we recommend in
those cases earlier in 2019 Google cloud
came out with a new product called
anthos and essentially that platform
does exactly what you asked we have seen
that customers are running their
applications on-premise in Google cloud
as well as other cloud providers and the
management of that becomes very ornery
now you're looking at separate config
management separate monitoring platforms
separate logging platforms and anthos
seeks to unify all of that we pull all
of the underlying hardware together and
allow you to
manage your on-premise and your hybrid
cloud multi cloud environments in one
place if we dive a little bit deeper the
way that we do it on premise is that we
have a tool called gke on premise which
allows you to implement a
containerization strategy in your
on-premise environments do you have an
example of a customer that is leveraging
anthos and using on-premise and cloud
together yes actually we have a very big
banking customer who's using Cisco
hyperflex
as well as anthos today to really do
exactly that they've found that it's
been able to simplify their monitoring
logging and config management and
they're still able to get access to all
the benefits of cloud and and it's as if
they were deployed cloud native but
their underlying hardware is still on
premise and that just reminded me
another exciting announcement was my
great for anthos which I know actually
lets customers move their VM based
workloads to the cloud and convert them
into containers which is amazing because
you can support edge deployments you can
actually migrate from compute engine
on-premise other clouds so I think this
is going to be very exciting for the
future as well absolutely and that's
actually why we're seeing a lot of
financial institutions have interest in
anthos is because they're running these
data driven applications which really
hits that sweet spot for
containerization because you know
instead of having a monolithic
application you can really break it down
into its appropriate components and
anything that you need to put a web or
mobile front-end on top of really lends
itself to that use case very well so for
those that are wondering how can I get
started in that decision-making process
what is there to recommend oh my gosh
there's a number of resources I would
say that my favorite is probably we have
a set of reference guides available on
cloud.google.com which I think will be
linked below that that are a great
getting started guide and help you to
think through what it actually means to
migrate your business also we have a
variety of professional services
resources and internally that
organization is called PSO and so we can
absolutely leverage workshops that they
have to to help you out as well awesome
well thank you so much for being on the
show we went over a ton of information
so thanks again
absolutely this was a lot of fun
you so much for having me everyone I
encourage you all to check out the
resources below and check out our other
series stack chat where we go into
actual examples and bring on customers
to talk about how they're implementing
our technology and migration patterns
let us know what you think of migration
are you doing lift and shift multi-cloud
what tools are you using comment below
and join us next time for eyes on
enterprise
[Music]
you
[Music]